trying to make a thumbnail for this
video I have no idea I don't even know
what to do for the intro what we
mechanic's resurrection here we go
so mechanic resurrection is a much
needed sequel to the cult classic film
the mechanic what you don't remember
that yeah no one else does either came
out like five and a half years ago no
one gave you [ __ ] then no one gives a
[ __ ] now sometimes my hobby here does
feel like work I'll let you know that so
in mechanic resurrection Jason Statham's
character is presumed dead he hasn't
killed anyone in a while he's no longer
at hitman he's out of the game
he meets Jessica Alba they bang they've
known each other for about nine hours so
Big Daddy kidnaps her for leverage over
Jason Statham's like oh you really care
about this girl yeah totally right so
kill these three people then I'll set a
phrase and now he has to go and kill
these people for this [ __ ] for this
girl he doesn't really know her care
about but he does turns about her so
much in fact he gave her his father's
watch in the movie I want to be honest
this movie lost me from the beginning in
the first 45 minutes which was probably
closer to the first 30 minutes but she's
probably actually the first 15 to 20
minutes you just felt like forever
this is the sloppiest setup I've seen in
a movie in a while and when the movie
could have been edited to just be better
at just I hate that shit's to-do list my
time how about have Jason Statham's
character who's been out of the game for
a few years no change there he's with
Jessica Alba's character from the
beginning of this movie and they're
married or something they've been
together for a few years and the big
baddie finds out he's alive he has a
wife and kidnaps his wife for leverage
leverage that we totally buy and now
Jason Statham is trying to do these
kills for him to save the woman he
actually loves it'll save us 20 minutes
of a [ __ ] force romance and will
actually by the fact that he actually
does care about this girl I guess come
on and this is that moment you realize
in this video I've so far only bitched
about the first 20 minutes of it what's
there to say about the rest of it I mean
the rest of it sloppiest [ __ ] to the
shitty green-screen filmed on location
in Studio B how about the fact that this
dude had a flak jacket on and Jason
Statham pulled the pin to her grenade
and flipped him around and used him as a
human shield when the grenade blew up
wiping everyone out in front of him and
then just blasting him back a grenade he
was like a foot from it me flak jackets
are tough and everything but I mean it's
like a nuke proof fridge I'm just not
going to buy it he's going around with
his unlimited
no seriously just see where he's writing
this boat and he is just popping shots
with the same gun never reloading like
what you have the red headband from
Metal Gear Solid seriously unlimited
ammo he finally ran out of ammo but how
long was that clip it was like 50 shots
I'm not gonna say this movie doesn't
have some enjoyment in it I mean by the
end when he's just writing this boat and
you finally just given up on everything
yeah okay shit's going down and you're
just seeing Statham kill everybody and
that's just the minimal amount of
enjoyment you can find is the fact that
he's just killing folks and one of the
missions he's scuffling with this dude I
mean noise is happening and this dude's
bodyguards are outside the room the
doors open there's they hear it but they
didn't hear it why because she's not
supposed to question the mechanic you
are and you can't help it guys in the
end the mechanic had a couple of cool
ish action sequences that happen in it
but all in all the setup pacing was
[ __ ] atrocious it was the worst and
it's so damaging for the movie because
the setup is supposed to get you in mode
for the movie when you don't buy the
setup you just kind of don't buy the
rest of it the green screen was [ __ ] the
shaky cam was [ __ ] suspending your
disbelief is one thing this movie just
it overreached
it's too much I can't suspend my
disbelief this much all I made for a
movie that was just checking my watch
just end so I could leave I'll say
you're not gonna remember this [ __ ]
thing at t-minus one day yep already
forgot you know it'll make it better
honorable sponsorship that's right this
review was wonderfully brought to us by
audible go to audible.com slash John's
get yourself a 30-day free trial of
audible select among an audiobook
library that audio wise and digitally is
more massive than the beauty in the
beasts library yeah that's real like the
lost world by Michael Crichton which
they do have on audible and I will tell
you this is such a completely different
experience than it was in the movie I'm
telling I have not actually seen a movie
go so far away from its source material
as the lost world does so if you didn't
like the lost world movie doesn't
necessarily mean you won't like this
lost world again follow the link below
to audible.com slash John's get yourself
a 30 day free trial of audible because
free is good by some mechanic
resurrection have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you